[Music]
[Applause]
hello there i am naz perez and welcome
to a fantastical new episode of rt
essentials as you all know it is a
dangerous business going out the door
you step onto the road and if you don't
keep your feet there's no knowing where
you might be swept off to but fear not
you can now get all the adventure you
need without leaving the sofa thanks to
the rising popularity of the fantasy
genre specifically in the television
format so let's escape reality and
journey to worlds unknown where dragons
fly and wizards roam all in the comfort
of your home that rhymes these are our
picks for the best fantasy tv shows
merlin you're a hero
thank you melon
not to me to your people
right
you think different
maybe i know something they don't
which is
you know
it's your cabbage head up first is the
british series merlin originally airing
on the bbc in september of 2008. now i
know i don't need to explain who merlin
is even if you're not obsessed with all
things enchanted like we are but you've
most likely heard of the mythological
wizard who featured prominently an
arthurian legend and became one of the
most important literary figures of the
middle ages this series reimagines the
tale of merlin and the prince turned
king arthur pendragon a servant and his
master but their relationship expands
beyond formalities and the two develop a
strong bond as trusted friends and
companions there's just one itsy-bitsy
problem merlin is clearly a magical
being wielding his powers to guide
arthur towards his destiny as the king
of camelot but arthur blames magic for
the death of his father and vows to
execute anyone caught practicing the
dark arts
this time it seems there really is
nowhere with my dagger at your back
what happened to you have gone
as a child you were so kind so
compassionate
i grew up
now this dynamic creates a rising
tension throughout the series with
merlin's secret always on the brink of
unraveling and arthur growing
increasingly suspicious co-creator
julian murphy was influenced by how the
show smallville developed an origin
story for superman and he wanted to take
the same approach with arthur and merlin
so the decision to make them
contemporaries as opposed to merlin
being an old man and arthur much younger
was there from the start and the
showrunners would steal the bits of
arthurian myth that they liked and
ignore the bits that they didn't now
this gave the series a contemporary feel
which helped it reach a wider and
younger audience eventually being
broadcast in 183 countries and streaming
on netflix and amazon prime merlin ran
for five seasons 65 episodes and was
nominated for numerous accolades which
included a win for best visual effects
at the 2011 baptist
outlander
well doesn't it bother you that
i'm not a virgin
well uh
no
as long as it doesn't bother you that
i am
what i can one of us should can what
they're doing
outlander is a historical drama based on
the novel series of the same name
written by diana gabaldon now the show
follows claire randall a former british
army nurse in world war ii and her
husband frank an mi6 officer looking
forward to his new career as an oxford
historian suddenly claire is transported
back in time to 1743 and finds herself
in a mysterious world where her freedom
and life are threatened now in order to
survive claire marries jaime fraser a
warrior with a complicated past and a
disarming sense of humor their
relationship grows more passionate and
intimate and now claire finds herself
caught between two vastly different men
and two inharmonious lives screenwriter
and producer ronald moore who had worked
on star trek and the reimagined
battlestar galactica began developing
outlander with sony picture studios back
in 2012 now moore put together a
top-notch writing team and in june of
2013 stars picked up the project
ordering 16 episodes
you're jamie fraser
aren't you
[Music]
um
who asks
[Music]
you a message from your loss
[Music]
my name is brianna
i'm your daughter
star ceo chris albrecht thought that
outlander was a different kind of show
than anything that had ever been on tv
part of what set the series apart was
its blend of action and fantasy and
having a feminist focus with a strong
central romance but don't be mistaken
because this isn't just another campy
romantic costume drama outlander is a
dark harsh and often violent portrayal
of a culture plagued with war and
barbarism the show's graphic content has
even led to backlash with some critics
and publications questioning quote how
much violence is too much how much is
too much i mean i'd say the battle
between the mountain and the red viper
in game of thrones was too much i mean
i'm still not over that one but hold
that thought scrutiny aside outlander
has received mostly positive reviews
it's been nominated for several emmys in
golden globes and just released its
sixth season on stars there's also a
prequel series currently in the works so
fingers crossed that it holds up to the
original
the witcher magic doesn't work on me
silver duster silver is from monsters
if we cross swords
[Music]
if you're looking for an
all-encompassing fantasy adventure add
the witcher to the top of your binge
list monsters magic sword fights destiny
i mean what more could you want the
series even stars mr mustache gate
himself henry cavill
it's based on the polish book series of
the same name the witcher and it follows
geralt orivia a mutated beast hunter who
struggles to find his place in a world
in which people are often the most
wicked creatures of them all now geralt
wanders across a fictional medieval
landmass known as the continent and can
i just say we just love us some
fictional land masses middle earth
westeros i mean all that space for
dragons to stretch their wings and for
epic battles like the one at sodon hill
which coincided with geralt finally
meeting the magical princess siri played
by freya allen
child of the
place
elder
blood
us
now show runner lauren schmidt his rick
was still working as a writer and
executive producer on the netflix series
the umbrella academy when she started
developing the witcher which means that
for a while she was actually on double
superhero series duty not to say that
the witcher and the umbrella academy are
very similar but hysteric's ability to
blend humor with the serious and
supernatural and to create an
unpredictable tone is prevalent in both
series the witcher season 1 was released
in its entirety on december 20th 2019
and consisted of eight episodes now
according to a report released by
netflix in 2020 this first season was
viewed by over 76 million people just
within its first month of release at the
time this was netflix most watch
original series launch but it was
eventually surpassed by shows like
bridgerton and squid games a second
season of the witcher was released in
2021 and the series has been renewed for
a third season with a prequel entitled
the witcher blood origin set for release
in 2022
the magicians
i'm sorry it's okay
thanks for reminding me it's there the
magicians is the story of quentin
coldwater a grad student at breakbills
magic school where students learn how to
cast spells and fight monsters and you
thought hogwarts was the only one how
ridiculous
now quintin has been fascinated by the
idea of a magical world since he was a
kid but now that he's older him and his
fellow student friends have discovered
that this magical world is not only real
but it possesses serious dangers to
humanity quentin and company eventually
find their way to the enchanted land of
fillery where talking animals run
rampant now if this all sounds familiar
that's part of the point the magicians
doesn't shy away from the obvious tropes
that will undoubtedly come to mind when
watching if you're intended to tell our
people those lies
then i'm sorry
but that's not gonna happen
if your intent was to double cross me mr
key plot point crisp
i'm a [ __ ] magician
now the series is based on the 2009
novel of the same name written by lev
grossman which was first optioned by
executive producer michael london in
2011. it was originally intended for the
fox broadcast company but after the
original pilot failed to get the green
light london hired writer sarah gamble
and john mcnamara to write a new pilot
which they eventually took to sci-fi who
did indeed order a pilot now with gamble
and mcnamara also serving as executive
producers sci-fi picked up the show for
a 13-episode first season run which
first aired in december of 2015. now
critical reception was overall positive
with the los angeles times writing that
harry potter meets gossip girl in the
magicians and it is a good match though
the show wasn't exactly a knockout from
the jump it's certainly seen an increase
in its fan base and overall reception
with seasons three and five both having
100 tomato meter scores yes you heard
that right
nothing short of magic now the fifth and
final season aired in january of 2020
and all episodes are now available on
netflix so get to binging
game of thrones
faces are for no one
you are still someone
into someone the faces are as good as
poison
[Music]
what's happening
what's happening
as i mentioned earlier still not over
the prince oberyn and mountain fight but
i'll set my feelings aside because it is
time to discuss what is widely
considered to be one of the greatest if
not the greatest television series of
all time game of thrones like many of
the selections on this list and
countless fantasy features as well i
mean game of thrones was adapted from a
novel actually a series of novels
entitled a song of ice and fire written
by george r.r martin true to martin's
best-selling books game of thrones is
set on the fictional continents of
westeros and essos and features an
ensemble of characters with complex
story arcs now this one really has it
all kings and queens knights renegades
liars and thieves dragons wolves witches
and spells politics religion insane
battles and straight up enophiles like
peter dinklage's character tyrion
lannister but i mean that's just what he
does he drinks and he knows things
speaking of dinklage though this cast is
electric amelia clark as the dragon
queen sophie turner is sansa stark and
of course kit harrington is jon snow who
according to egret doesn't know things
back in 2005 roughly six years before
the series aired time magazine had
already called george rr martin the
american tolkien which as i'm sure my
fantasy fanatical friends would agree is
the most precious of compliments i mean
it's only right that such a prolific and
imaginative writer could inspire a show
that mirrors his talents and does
justice to his work lannister targaryen
baratheon stark tyrell
they're all just spokes on a wheel
this one's on top then that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground
it's a beautiful dream
stopping the wheel
you're not the first person who's ever
jumped
i'm not going to stop the wheel
i'm going to break the wheel
and we can thank siri's co-creators
david benioff and db weiss for
understanding martin's vision and
ensuring that an adaptation would find
the right home that home was hbo and
rightfully so as martin admitted that he
quote never imagined it anywhere else
hbo acquired the television rights to
the novels and development began in 2007
with benioff weiss and martin as
co-executive producers now i'll spare
you the typical rollercoaster details of
development hell and skip to the show's
premiere in april of 2011 which was
watched by 2.2 million with viewership
drastically increasing each episode and
season i mean by season seven the
average per episode viewing figure had
increased to almost 33 million across
all platforms despite what many fans and
critics considered a disappointing final
season game of thrones has had an
unrivaled influence on pop culture and
the fantasy genre having won 59 emmy
awards the most of any drama series ever
and the legacy continues with an
upcoming prequel series entitled house
of the dragon set for release in august
of 2022 but i mean still did they have
to do that to prince oberyn i'm not over
it
his dark materials
i told you if i fight
i die you owe me a debt now you can
repay it do as i ask don't fight these
men you owe her that too
damn yorick you're racking up debts
faster than me
heard there was some action occurring i
thought i'd come see what's going on
hello again mr sisselman
having fun i hope so
next up his dark materials once again
based on novels of the same name this
time a trilogy written by english author
philip pullman now set in a multi-world
reality the series follows the orphan
lyra who while searching for a kidnapped
friend uncovers a sinister plot
involving stolen children and a
mysterious phenomenon called dust now
you might be familiar with this story if
you've seen the feature film the golden
compass then you know all about lyra and
her search for children kidnapped by the
gobblers the movie was an adaptation of
pullman's northern lights the first
installment in his series and it was one
of new line cinema's most expensive
films to make it even went on to win an
oscar and bafta for best visual effects
gruman made reference to a certain
natural phenomenon only seen in the
lands of the north i believe this is
what he was referring to i took this
photogram a few days ago
the aurora the northern lights yes
that's right
when seen with the ordinary emulsion but
i'd like you to look at it again using
mine
city in the sky
now you think there would be no need for
another adaptation with the same
characters and story so soon but the
golden compass wasn't as much of a
commercial success as studios had hoped
it would be especially considering the
gargantuan budget so the making of any
sequels was unlikely this left an
opening and after several years the
rights to the story reverted to pullman
and in 2015 bbc one announced that it
was developing a series adaptation of
the trilogy with the intention of
changing some of the book and film
elements to give the series a modern
feel in 2018 hbo signed on as a
co-producer and distributor and in
november of 2019 his dark materials
premiered on bbc one in the uk and hbo
in the us and other markets
now critical reception was mostly
positive with many praising the special
effects and star-studded cast
the wheel of
[Music]
the hand of the time fall on you logan
hablar
and take back that which nature itself
does not wish you to hold
the wheel of time follows moyrane a
member of a magical organization who
takes five young people on a journey
believing that one of them might be the
reincarnation of the dragon a powerful
individual prophesies to save the world
or destroy it the series is based on the
late robert jordan's high fantasy novels
of the same name which span 14 volumes
and have sold over 90 million copies
worldwide making it one of the best
selling fantasy series since the lord of
the rings this series was developed by
rafe judkins who aside from working as a
writer on shows like chuck and agents of
shield was actually contestant on the
11th season of survivor impressively
finishing in third place perhaps it was
judkins his competitive nature and
ability to withstand harsh conditions
that made him the right fit for such a
gigantic undertaking like adapting a
timeless fantasy novel for television
the world doesn't need a dragon like me
what's happening oh you stupid boy
you took this from shadow
hold him down
both of you
now in fact over the past 20 years there
have been several attempts to adapt
jordan's work to film and tv but it took
the right players and the right set of
circumstances to finally bring this saga
to life and in the proper fashion the
success of shows like game of thrones
and the handmaid's tale proved that
books made great tv and judkins was able
to identify the important elements of
the wheel of time novels and condensos
into a format fit for streamers now the
series was released on amazon prime in
november of 2021 and was the streamer's
most watched premiere of the year and
one of their most watched ever a second
season is currently in production but
there's no official release date as of
yet hopefully they can spin that wheel
of time a little faster so we can get on
with the story
buffy the vampire slayer you forget
metal can't hurt me
there's something you forgot about too
it's in sunrise nine hours [ __ ] okay so
buffy the vampire slayer wasn't based on
a novel it was based on a film but that
doesn't mean it's any less monumental as
a matter of fact one could argue that
this series along with the sopranos
completely revolutionized the tv drama
and there's no denying that without
buffy shows like vampire diaries and
supernatural wouldn't exist i mean as
the show title reveals buffy is a slayer
one in a long line of young women chosen
for a specific mission seek out and
destroy vampires demons and other forces
of darkness but unlike her predecessors
buffy establishes a group of supportive
friends to assist her in her battles
against evil which are plentiful because
she happens to live in sunnydale which
sits atop a gateway to the realm of
demons sarah michelle gellar starred in
the title role a performance that made
her an international sensation and
earned her a golden globe nomination for
best actress in tv drama what can you
have been thinking
you are the slayer lives depend upon you
i make
allowances for your youth but i expect a
certain amount of responsibility and
instead of which you enslave yourself to
this this
cult
you don't like the color though the
series was widely popular and critically
revered it didn't fully receive the
major award show recognition that it
deserved but that didn't stop buffy the
vampire from having an unparalleled
impact on pop culture and spawning
novels comics video games and a spin-off
series called angel which took place in
what is now referred to as the
buffyverse buffy lasted for seven
seasons 144 episodes and consistently
ranks high on the list of the greatest
tv shows of all time
shadow and bone
follow
last but certainly not least is shadow
and bone a netflix series based on two
sets of books by leigh bardugo the
shadow and bone trilogy and the six of
crows duology now bardugo is the
mastermind behind what is known as the
grishaverse a shared universe that
encompasses all the characters and books
that are set in the realm of the grisha
what is a grisha you might ask well
they're magical beings with the ability
to summon natural elements and
manipulate matter but if you have to ask
you're probably not one of them or maybe
you are because the protagonist in the
series alina didn't always know that she
was a grisha and she's a particularly
powerful one with the ability to control
light the general have me make these
for your demonstration this evening
they're
lovely
what do they do
they'll make it easier to split one beam
into
two your show of power will determine
who remains our ally
[Music]
now unfortunately grisha aren't always
admired and once word spreads that alana
is a sun summoner sinister forces plot
against her now shadow and bones eight
episode first season was released in
april 2021 and it's received critical
praise for its pitch perfect cast
costumes and sense of humor and a second
season is currently in production
and there you have it my friends our
selection for the best fantasy tv shows
now don't go challenging us to a duel if
your favorite series didn't make this
list there's so many worthy selections
and so little time but do not fret
because there are plenty of new episodes
of rt essentials coming your way so i'm
sure we'll get there eventually thanks
again for tuning in i am naz perez and
never forget what you are the rest of
the world will not wear it like armor
and it can never be used to hurt you
[Music]